[Music]
pepper Kanye West has prune himself the
equal of really anyone on the planet at
dominating public discourse with just a
few hundred characters on Twitter two
weeks ago he tweeted this quote you
don't have to agree with Trump but the
mob can't make me not love him
we are both dragon energy he is my
brother I love everyone I don't agree
with everything anyone does that's what
makes us individuals and we have the
right to independent thought well that
was a bomb that went off and he's been
under attack ever since what does it
mean take three steps back the Kanye
interlude can we learn something from it
Jason Whitlock has been watching
carefully he's an anchor at fs1 in
recent op-ed he called Kanye statement
quote one of the best tweets of all time
he joins us tonight to explain what he
means Jason what do you mean by that why
is it one of the best tweets of all time
well I think what Kanye is trying to do
is open black America's mind to the fact
that perhaps we've chosen a bad strategy
by swallowing all of the Democratic
Party and liberalism hole I say in my
column in The Wall Street Journal that
in the immediate aftermath of the civil
rights movement in the 1960s Democrats
marketed to us liberalism as the
solution to all of our problems and
liberalism now is like be cigarette it's
been marketed us the same as the
cigarette
fashionable sophisticated it's supposed
to be liberating but I think it needs a
surgeon general's warning hazardous to
your family and all the values you were
taught as a child I think us as
african-americans we have to examine why
are we the only ethnic group that has
gone in Hall wholly with one political
party no one has to compete for our
votes exam we are chained to an ideology
that just isn't working over the last 50
60 years liberalism the swallowing of it
whole our families have been destroyed
our children lost and confused our black
men incarcerated and emasculated and
we've moved away from the traditional
values that have always defined us I
think we've made a mistake
politics is if you give your vote away
for free don't get anything in return
and so maybe the hysterical reaction to
the Kanye West's tweet is the reaction
of a party that knows that once people
figure that out like it's got a major
problem on its hands so you need to tamp
down any independent thought immediately
or else you can get out of control
and it's being tamp down as viciously as
anything I've ever seen
you know when they call in the great
writer Donaghy C coats basically I call
him the overseer of black fault he's
there to keep everyone in line with the
group think that the only solution is
liberalism for black America's problems
if that were the case our problems would
be being solved much faster because
ninety ninety-five percent of us are
afraid to even admit that we have
conservative values and we've been so
we've moved away from our church
upbringing we've been the most religious
people in America for years hundreds of
years and we're moving more secular
we're moving away from the church our
religion now is liberalism and the
Democratic Party is our church and it's
just not working for so if Kanye West's
whose guy who's like not just one of
those popular black Americans but one of
those popular Americans just across the
board if he doesn't stand a chance of
just raising this question because it's
a totally valid question then how you
know who does well actually he does
stand a chance because when someone like
Kanye speaks out he creates space for
others to speak out because anybody that
has said and you got a Tucker I'm a non
voter I don't really like politics much
at all
and so if you just say you know what I
think Trump has a good idea here you get
kicked out of the black race that Kanye
is saying I don't agree with everything
Trump believes in I'm disagrees with
Trump and the Republican Party and
conservatives on a lot of issues but
he's not willing to cast someone out of
the human race just because he disagrees
with
if I cast everybody out that I disagreed
with I would have no one great I know
that feeling so well Jason Whitlock it
is great to see you as always thank you
for doing that
thank you Doug